609 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy well we talk a lot
about Tropicana the Centennial Bowl the
95 515 at Charleston many others well
they are not the only projects that
might be driving you crazy so we're
going to go down to Henderson where
viewer Maryland had a question about the
repaving of Pecos between Windmill and
the 215 Southern Beltway it's been a
thing since October of last year she'd
heard that a couple of major
intersections may be shutting down there
well Henderson's public works department
tells me that this Saturday February 4th
Wigwam is going to be closed in both
directions at Pecos from five in the
morning till 10 at night traffic on
Pecos going to be down to one lane in
each Direction Wigwam drivers you'll see
signs urging you to get up to Windmill
or go down to Pebble and then Sunday
February 5th it's Pebble that's going to
be closed at Pecos 5 a.m to 10 p.m Pecos
again down to one lane Pebble drivers
will be directed to either windmill or
the 215 you could probably do Wigwam as
well buckle up drive carefully and
please put down that phone you can join
the driving you crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com